- There's a film playing
across the street.
- It's playing at 5:00.
- We can make it. There's
going to be 5 minutes of trailers.
- I want to get a good
seat, you know?
- A good seat from which to
watch Asgard burn.
- Lets show some movies.
- We're here to heckle a movie!
- 75 cents.
- So what actually happens in this?
- Movies are dreams that
you never forget.
- Please retain your stub sir.
- The refreshments are right over there.
- Hey, uh, do you
want anything?
- Popcorn!
- Butter or plain?
- Extra butter.
- Some Diet Coke please.
- This seat taken?
- Not bad seats at all.
- [Japanese]
Our film is starting.
- Roll film!
- I missed a reel change.
- [French] I like looking back at
people’s faces in the dark.
- Sounds like a comedy.
- It's comedy...
and sexy...
...and it's action.
- Gotcha!
- Total entertainment experience.
- Boy, did you see that?
- I gotta see it again. Ernie?